article l'encodeur zebina dit j'ai
embauché des gens pour modérer il ya
treize mille personnes qui modère les
comptes alors sur la mode sur cette
question de la modération il ya la
question de l'encadrement légal
c'est important après il ya un défi sur
la vitesse d'exécution et c'est là que
nos avis sont un petit peu différent
nous pensons qu'il est important de
protéger notamment quand les contenus
sont particulièrement dangereux donc
terrorisme et ne pédo pornographique des
contenus qui sont porteurs de vraiment
de danger en soi est plutôt exigé le
retrait tout de suite et prendre le
temps des vérifications et corrigé airs
et réédité le contenu si nécessaire
plutôt que d'attendre une décision
judiciaire qui serait long et la
novation c'est aussi le caractère
transfrontalier de l'injonction puisque
souvent par exemple une un contenu
dangereux peut être vu dans un pays mais
la plateforme être hébergés dans un
autre pays européen et donc dans le cas
des retraits des contenus terrorisme ont
appris cette décision
ça a été approuvé dans notre commission
libe et bientôt au parlement européen
nous retrouverons le débat pour le
retrait des contenus haineux ou
illicites
on voit efficacité versus sécurité
juridique
il faut clairement que plus l'outil
d'encadrement est puissant plus le
contre-pouvoir à la surveillance du
respect des libertés individuelles soit
assuré dans le même temps sur la
question de délai on est d'accord donc
le fait que les plateformes puisse
retirer un contenu puis qu'il y ait une
confirmation juridiques judiciaires
pardon de la non-conformité avec
injonction de retirer définitivement le
contenu ou de leur maître si voilà s'il
s'avère que ce n'était pas un contenu
problématique ici on parle du terrorisme
on peut parler aussi d'autres types de
contenus dans le cas du terrorisme ce
qui nous pose réellement problème c'est
que l'état donc dans le cadre de la
coopération transfrontalière sera chargé
de définir l'autorité compétente pour
nous ça doit être l'autorité judiciaire
ça ne peut pas être une autorité
publique
un cabinet ministériel par exemple parce
qu'on voit dans les pays où il ya un
recul de l'état de droit par prenons la
hongrie prenons la pologne
on pourrait
recevoir en tant que belge en tant que
français une injonction du gouvernement
hongrois ou polonais de retirer un
certain type de contenu au nom de la
lutte contre le terrorisme au nom de
contenus terroristes même si la belgique
où la france a estimé qu'il ne s'agit
pas de contenu terroristes et quelles
sont les dérives pour les droits
fondamentaux là c'est précisément que si
ça va à l'encontre des intérêts de la
pologne de la hongrie dans un contexte
de recul de l'état de droit et
d'autoritarisme et bien des communautés
lgbt cuit pour air moment donné des
opposants politiques pourraient un
moment donné être concernées et c'est là
qu'on les garde-fous doivent être
beaucoup plus solide que la proposition
qui est sur la table alors
[Musique]